neuf ans après le départ vers un
ailleurs de jean linard la mobilisation
des bénévoles et sa cathédrale
l'oeuvre de sa vie sont intactes de
strasbourg
eh bien écoutez uniquement par sympathie
vis-à-vis de l'association jean linard
et pour l'entretien annuel la cathédrale
avec ma collègue l'attendre en train de
le dénoncer les gradins de
l'amphithéâtre où il ya donc des
spectacles en était cette ancienne
carrière de silex transformé en lieu de
culte naturelles et artistiques doit
retrouver tout son éclat il faut retirer
les feuilles et les branches mortes
redonner des couleurs aux mosaïques et
aux sculptures
l'ensemble est à vendre depuis plusieurs
années chacun pourra bientôt en acheter
un morceau une société coopérative
d'intérêt collectif est en création
keira a tous les arguments pour abbas
est magnifique c'est un l'endroit dans
lequel on peut venir se promener à
toutes les saisons et on verra quelque
chose de différent
c'est un endroit qui est dense de poésie
de magie c'est une oeuvre d'art en
pleine nature c'est un lieu unique les
complètement singulier
ça ressemble à rien d'autre à rien de
connu et je sais pas moi il se dégage
une énergie particulière c'est cesser du
merveilleux c'est voilà donc je n'ai pas
du tout envie que ça disparaisse donc
voilà je suis très très content de venir
l'entretenir très régulièrement la
société oui ça c'est sûr ah ça j'en sais
rien encore par mais assez certain j'ai
vraiment envie de m'investir
complètement la part devrait coûter 20
euros une goutte d'eau pour s'offrir une
cathédrale avec un toit en ciel bleu
ouverte à tous les croyants tous les bon
dieu mais aussi à tous les humains même
ceux qui ne croient en rien il suffit
d'aimer la nature le ciel les chants
d'oiseaux et les couleurs de la vie
comme l'artiste humaniste qu'il a
construite